oh we're back with my dear friend jimmy
fallon
oh in the house come on we're here
physically here
talking to each other you guys are
awesome
now he has written a number one
oh my goodness oh come on oh
come on now that's what i'm talking
about
come on more sweeps deal christmas
come on that's what's up look at that
that's the biggest book i've ever seen
oh my god i feel like
that should that's that's actual size or
something
that's actual size yeah exactly yeah the
book is uh eight thousand dollars
i should mention yeah i've only sold one
and you need to be a
bodybuilder to read it exactly um well
we asked our
resident book reviewer jonah larson uh
to come in and talk to jimmy so let's
welcome him now
jonah are you there oh hey bud
look at that oh hi jimmy i haven't seen
you
in so long and i'm so excited to be back
on the show and i'm wearing my special
christmas hat to get
into the christmas spirit you look at
that that is unbelievable you are so
talented where are you zooming from
i'm zooming from wisconsin so it's super
cold
and this hat is stuff it's freezing here
jonah have you ever had a juicy lucy
i have yeah so good it's a hamburger do
you know this
yeah i've heard of the juicy lucy it's a
hamburger it's a hamburger with
molten lava cheese in the center of it
and when you bite it it dribbles and it
burns your face and it's the hottest
thing in the whole white world but it's
so delicious it's really great
you've got to have a juicy lucy have
jonah send you one and it's cake week
is jonah what's what's your cake what's
your cake of choice
my cake of choice i have two number one
is the classic yellow cake with the
chocolate buttercream
and number two is just the all-around
classic chocolate cake who is this kid
he's unbelievably
so cute so jonah
what did you think of jimmy's book oh i
absolutely loved five sleeps until
christmas
i'm gonna start off with as soon as you
open the book
i love his dedication and the message
that he put
right at the start about recognizing the
wonder
and the joy and the excitement of the
world and of christmas
and i absolutely adored that message but
i also loved the illustrations
because they were so bright and fun and
vibrant and colorful
and it was the whole book was just like
that and i absolutely
love that i also loved
that they were how many sleeps are there
till christmas
not how many days and that was just
really cute and fun and
added to the overall effect of the book
and all the little details that you
dotted all the little details about the
book about how
in different pictures his christmas list
is getting longer
and i also thought it was super funny
when
he was just about to see santa through
his telescope in his room
and he falls asleep and as soon as he
falls asleep his
dog gets to see santa and his reindeers
dude this is
all right let's go to commercial this is
a great review that's it let's go that's
we're going to go to the oh my god
that the picture is inside the telescope
too oh my god
yes it's there's just so many things to
love
and when i think of everything of the
book
the sleeps the colorful all the
wonderful messages in it
there's no way that i can't give it a
five out of five
crochet loop right here oh my god
loops five out of five for me
thank you i wanted to thank you for
writing this book
because on the occasion that i read a
children's book
and it's as good as yours it makes me
think that they should be called
everybody books because everybody needs
a little christmas spirit
and a message about the wonder and the
joy and just excitement so thank you
very much for writing five sleeps till
christmas
who is this kid who is this kid
where is this kid from he's unbelievable
i'm a fan i watch you on the show
when you when you do your segments here
so uh does it
is it exciting to be famous jonah
i mean it's exciting to be famous but i
was super excited when i found out that
i got to meet jimmy fallon
we love you jonah thank you so much for
your insights into jimmy's book you are
brilliant you are the best
you